-Here's how it works,
we're gonna take turns
drawing one of these cards.
Each card has five
totally random questions on it.
One person asks the questions,
the other person
has to answer each question
as soon as it's asked.
And I mean immediately.
[ Vocalizes ]
-Alright.
-It doesn't matter --
-Is there a record
that I'm trying to beat?
'Cause I work well if
I'm competing against someone.
Is there a...
-Yeah you have to answer
all of the questions.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Is there-- d--
-It doesn't matter if the answer
is right or wrong, it just has
to be the very first thing
that pops into your head.
No this is very --
-Is there winning to this?
-Yes.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Because you're the guest, I'm
gonna read your questions first.
-But who's keeping score,
is what I'm asking.
♪♪
Ready for this?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It's called Think Fast!
The lighting changed, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Who did you
invite to your party?
-[ Stammers ]
Ronald McDonald.
-Why did you get kicked off
the airplane?
-Because I drank all
the alcohol!
-What's over there?
-A lion and a tiger.
-What do The Roots do
on the weekend?
-Uh, sleep in, I hope.
-Say something serious.
-Don't you dare try to tell me
what to say.
[ Bell dings ]
-Wow.
-Alright. Nice job, Amy.
Turns out you won that round.
-Oh, good!
-Now -- Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah it's easy to tell.
I got seven.
-It is my -- That sound means
you won the round.
-I got seven.
-Uh, yeah.
Now it's my turn. Whenever
you're ready, take the card.
-Alright.
-And go for it, yeah?
-Here we go. Alright.
-Alright. Here we go.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God.
-Okay, okay, okay. Here we go.
-Yeah.
-You ready, Jimmy?
-And...
what's the popular new
video game called?
-Uh, Beezles.
-Who c--
Who can you always trust?
-Uh, George Sampson.
-What's the capital of Earth?
-Uh, You-Nigh-Gid.
[ Laughter ]
-You-Nigh-Gid?
When is tomorrow?
-Tomorrow?
[ Laughter ]
-How do you dance?
-Like this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]
-You do dance like that.
-Ooh. I just got it.
-You-Nigh-Gid.
-The Capital of Earth, I didn't
know what was happening.
Alright, it's time for the final
round though.
-Okay.
-In this round, we'll both
pick up a card with the same set
of questions.
We'll ask and answer them one at
a time, going back and forth.
-Mm.
-And there's only one winner.
-Yeah, how do we know who wins?
-The sound at the end.
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
-Oh, hoo!
-Okay.
-Here we go.
Now, will I go first or I'll ask
the first question.
-Okay.
I just want to find --
I just want to find my center
and just kind of get to
the space a little.
-I know, as soon as I...
Alright.
Get in the head space,
here we go.
-Who am I and what do I want.
Okay here we go.
-Alright. Here we go.
Ready?
[ Clears throat ]
What's up with Gary?
-He's always stealing things
from the refrigerator.
[ Laughter ]
How fast are trains?
-They're faster than cars.
[ Laughter ]
Your voice was changing.
-It makes it easier
when you do it like that.
-I know that voice, I like.
In France it's illegal
to do what?
-To tell people that they can't
park in front of your driveway.
[ Laughter ]
-Why are rainbows so magical?
-Because they're made of foam.
[ Laughter ]
-How do you win?
-By always cheating.
[ Laughter ]
-What -- What are the names of
the triplets?
-Gilda, Gertrude, and Fortran.
[ Laughter ]
-What -- Which sandwich is the
best sandwich?
-The one with
all the meat in it.
-I know, of course it is.
-How do you spell coffee?
-C-O-double-L-I-N-G.
-What is --
Who's good at tennis?
-The [Stutters] Fred's friend.
Fred's friend.
-Fred's friend is the best.
Judges?
[ Bell dings ]
That's it, now you have it.
That was Think Fast!
with Amy Poehler.
-Everybody, I am here with the
one and only Amy Poehler.
Oh, we love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Her new movie "Wine Country"
is out now and on Netflix soon.
We're about to play a new twist
on a classic game, charades,
called "Shouting Charades."
Now, here's how it works.
Just like charades,
where you pick a clue,
try to get your partner
to guess.
The only difference is
you can't use your hands
or your body at all.
You can only describe
how you would be moving.
And you have to shout it.
So, for example,
if the clue has five words,
instead of holding up
five fingers, you would say,
"I'm holding up five fingers!"
-Yeah.
-Okay, good.
So, now, before we begin,
let's both put our arms
in the official shouting --
-I believe this is the first
time that we've played this.
Is that right?
This is the maiden voyage?
-It is.
-I'm sorry. I just --
I think that's exciting.
-It is the first time.
Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Only the best.
-Alright.
-Only the best for you.
Alright, we'll put our hands in
these -- these sleeves.
Now we can't physically get out.
We cannot do this. Okay.
-This is good,
'cause I am a gesticulator.
-You are? Okay, good.
-I am.
You know what that means.
-Ready?
-Oh, Higgins,
good to see you, buddy.
This is Steve Higgins
right there.
Give it up for Steve Higgins.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sharp-dressed man.
Amy, you should go first.
-Thank you. I'm going to pick
lucky number seven.
-Oh!
-Number seven.
Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-[ Laughs ]
Okay.
Alright.
-Why would you touch me?
-[ Laughs ]
Okay, I'm standing up.
-Okay.
-And I'm holding up two fingers.
-Two words.
-Yes.
And then I'm also putting --
making action
like I'm doing something
with film, like I'm rolling --
-It's a movie.
-Yes.
-Oh, my God.
-Okay.
I'm holding up my two fingers.
-The same ones?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm holding up two fingers!
-Okay. Two words.
-Yes, I already told you that.
-Oh, the second word.
-Yes.
Okay. And then it's --
And then -- Oh.
-Hurry up!
-I'm moving around really fast,
like what you were doing
up there.
Like I'm really grooving
to the music.
-Oh, yes, dance.
-Yes.
-Yes. Dancing.
-Moving, grinding.
-Yes.
No, the first word.
-Dancing.
-Yes, that's --
-"Dirty Dancing"!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Love it!
-It's so hard.
-What number should I pick?
What -- Four.
-Four.
-Four. A strong four.
Okay.
-Take your time there.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't see that.
-Got it?
-No. Yes.
-Yes.
-You sure?
-Okay.
-Yeah.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa, the reaction.
-Alright.
Start the clock.
Alright, so I'm moving
my hands like I'm --
like it's something
that I'm going to read.
-A book.
-Yes.
-It's a book.
-Yeah, and it is --
-Hold --
-I think seven words.
-Okay.
-Oh, no.
I can't say that.
Sorry.
-You're holding up
seven fingers.
-I'm holding up seven fingers.
Sorry.
I'm going to say the...
-"Tale of Two Cities."
No.
-No, here's what I would do.
With one hand, I would make
a lightning bolt on my forehead.
-Oh, "Harry Potter Curse of --"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, alright,
and one of the words,
I would pretend that I'm
drinking out of something.
I would be sitting on a throne.
[ Laughter ]
-"Harry Potter and the King
of Something."
-No, no, but what would I
be drinking out of?
-Mead.
-No, what would I
be drinking out of?
-Oh, "Goblet of Fire"!
"Goblet of Fire"!
-Yes, yes, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's correct.
"Goblet of Fire."
-Oh, my gosh.
-Mead.
[ Laughs ]
I love you.
Oh, my gosh.
Alright, last one.
Here we go, final round.
-"Goblet of Fire."
Three, please.
Three for me, please, Higs.
-Three.
-Thank you, bud.
Alright.
-It's getting a little steamy
in my --
-Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
-Got it?
-Yep, yep, yep.
It's getting steamy in here.
-It is steamy in there, right?
-I don't want to shake your hand
when we're done.
'Cause it's really gross.
-Alright, here we go.
-Alright,
what would you be doing?
-Okay, I'm standing up.
I'm holding up three fingers.
-Three words.
-Yes.
And then I'm making the sign
again that I'm rolling film.
[ Laughter ]
-Rolling film.
It's a movie.
-You know, like cranking film.
-Yes, cranking -- I understand.
-Okay.
-And then I'm holding up
three fingers.
-Yes, three -- the third word.
-And I am placing something on
top of my head that is pointy
that makes me feel very regal.
And I'm in a throne.
And I'm --
-Crown.
-Yeah, and then I'm pointing
to myself after I do all that.
-Queen?
-Almost.
-Prince, king.
-Yes.
-So now I'm holding up
two fingers.
-Yes, the second word.
You're gesticulating
with your feet, by the way.
[ Laughter ]
You can't help it.
You're like --
-There ain't no coats
for my feet.
My feet are free!
Okay.
And then I'm --
[ Buzzer ]
Aah!
-Oh, no!
Oh, no, sorry.
That was my fault.
It was my fault.
Wait. Just do it again.
Tell me the second word.
I'll get it.
-I'm holding up two fingers
and I'm going like this.
Roar.
[ Laughter ]
-"The Lion King."
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to the one and only
Amy Poehler.
Now, Amy, I consider you
a very honest person.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
-Yeah, you're welcome.
Well, look,
we're both honest people.
I want to know
who's more honest.
It's time for Truth or Truth.
-♪ Truth or Truth ♪
-Alright.
You're up first, Amsters.
What's it gonna be?
Truth...or truth?
-Truth.
[ Clears throat ]
-What's your biggest fear?
-Easy.
Being mistaken for J.Lo.
[ Laughter ]
And then being asked to dance.
And dancing better than J.Lo.
[ Laughter ]
And J.Lo being angry.
-Easy.
-I don't want J.Lo
to be angry at me.
-[ Chuckling ] No.
-That's my biggest fear.
-Okay.
-Jimmy.
-Mm-hmm.
-Now it's your turn, I think.
Is this how this works?
-Yeah.
-Truth or truth?
-Truth.
-[ Clears throat ]
Where's someplace
you've never had sex?
[ Laughter ]
-In my 20s.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, I did run into Chuck
in the elevator once.
-So I've heard.
-Your turn!
-Fine!
-Truth or truth?
-[ Scoffs, laughs ]
Truth.
-What does your real voice
sound like?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-[ Accented lisping ]
What do you mean?
Do you mean when I'm speaking
my native tongue?
[ Laughter ]
Do you mean when I...
speak to my relatives
or my people I lauve [love]?
-"Lauve"?
-Yimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-It's Sofía Vergara
or something.
-[ Spits ]
-Oh, my God!
Sorry, doesn't mean any--
Sorry to say that.
-How dare you?
-I'm not comparing anything.
You're both --
-We're very different.
-Different. Very different.
Apologize.
-[ Normal voice ]
Jimmy, it's your turn.
And I mean, I've enjoyed
this game so far, but...
I'd like you to tell the truth.
Truth or truth?
-Okay, truth.
-What's in your pocket
right now?
[ Laughter ]
-A CD case of Bon Jovi's
2005 album "Have a Nice Day,"
but inside is Green Day's
"Dookie" CD.
[ Laughter ]
-Want me to prove it?
[ Laughs ]
Check this out, man.
Bang.
-Whoa.
-Bang.
That's "Dookie" right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, last one, Poehler!
-Both great songs.
-[ Laughs ] Truth --
Truth or truth?
Or truth.
-[ Sighs ]
I'm too old for dares.
I'm too smart for lies.
I'm too quick --
-Don't read your lower back
tattoo.
Just --
[ Laughter ]
Just say truth or truth.
-You're right, you're right.
I shouldn't say my tattoo,
I should live it.
You're right.
-[ Laughs ]
-I just -- I love it.
-"I shouldn't say my tattoo,
I should live it."
That's correct.
-Okay, truth.
-[ Laughs ]
Ah.
What's your Gmail password?
-PizzaHutMonkeyButt.orgy.
-[ Laughs ]
That is Truth or Truth.
Our thanks to Amy Poehler!
-My little guy
is still afraid of movies.
He won't go see movies, so --
-He's 5 now?
-He's 5,
and he just does a thing of,
like, you know,
he, like, talks a big game,
and then he's just like,
"Um, no, thanks."
Like, he just bails.
So when we had a screening of
"Inside Out," actually,
and all of his friends
were there,
and he just was like,
"I'm just gonna" --
like, he just pretended like
he had something else to do.
-As a 5-year-old?
-It was super cute, yeah.
-That's super cute,
and how's the older one?
-And Archie's
ready for anything.
In fact, the other day, he --
I walked by and he was with
some neighbors of ours,
and I was like,
"What are you doing?"
He's like,
"Mom, I'm watching Divergent."
I was like,
"Should you be watching?"
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
Should he be watching
"Divergent"?
-I don't know it, though.
-It might be too
something, right? Yeah.
-Yeah.
-It's violent or something.
I don't even know.
-We're talking about things
we didn't even prep.
-We don't care.
We don't need 'em.
I just want to know about
those kids.
Are they best friends?
-They're great.
They're so great.
Archie's doing this thing now,
though, where he's kind of
acting like, um --
he's the older brother and he
tortures his younger brother.
So...
-Yeah.
-...he psychologically
tortures him.
So, he just does really quiet,
like,
Kevin Spacey-like moves
where he just --
where Abel, my younger one,
will be like, "I can't wait to,"
you know, "play with my LEGOs,"
and Archie will be like,
"Those aren't your LEGOs."
[ Laughter ]
And he'll be like, "They're
mine, they're my LEGOs,"
and he'll be like,
"Not anymore."
And Abel will just immediately
start to cry, like,
and Archie will be like,
you know,
"If you want to play,
you have to talk to me first."
He's just constantly --
he's just constantly horrible.
-Yeah.
-He's just always telling him,
like, up is down and...
-Yeah, just whatever you can do
psychologically.
Are they going to see
"Star Wars,"
the big "Star Wars" movie?
-Well, I think they like --
again, they like the idea of it.
It's a little too
adult for them,
so I don't think
they're gonna see it,
but I think -- so no.
-Yeah.
They're not gonna see it, no.
-No.